d'accord là aussi c'est un grand pays
avec un énorme territoire 17,5 millions
de kilomètres carrés donc territoire ça
ne m'intéresse pas autant de pays
pauvres ça n'intéresse pas et alors vous
savez pourquoi il a la garde
il ya des richesses un tout petit peu
mais par rapport à la réussite est de la
sibérie mille fois plus riche que le
cren donc c'est pas la richesse qu'ils
étaient là avec l intéresse et puis il
ya autre chose économiquement la russie
c'est un tout petit pays avec le pib du
portugal mais ça veut dire que en fait
ils ont s'il n'avait pas l'arsenal
nucléaire s'il y avait de l'union
soviétique personne lui parlerai donc
c'est ça donc donc bon vous pour vous
c'est quoi l'issue du conflit les suces
et il va s'enliser dans cette guerre il
pourra pas la gagner d'ailleurs il ya le
général ivachov l'année des vaches of
ancien membre des deux du service de
renseignement militaire qu'elle nie sil
attaque la gueule à l'ukraine la russie
est perdu il a il a signé ce lundi la
signale la reconnaissance des deux
républiques
ça veut dire que l'union soviétique
c'est une fédération il ya 85
composantes dans l'union de dents dans
la russie maintenant puisqu'il a reconnu
les république fantoche n'importe quelle
république de russie peut pour clamer
son indépendance et on va se retrouver
avec un outil avec les diamants or le
pétrole le gaz qui va se proclamer
l'indépendance qui va signer l'accord
avec la chine et et poutine
ont pensé et est ce qu'il est possible
la claque est ce que je voulais je vous
la pose aussi à vous qui voyez une
troisième guerre mondiale et que les la
france qui interviennent les états unis
que la chine prenne prenne fait et que
vos ciboure pour pour les russes c'est
possible ou pas on est à ça en a ça on
est à sa hawks et 6 ils ont bombardé ce
matin les vifs les leafs et à 50 km de
la frontière polonaise je vous ai montré
bien sûr
derrière de la frontière c'est l'union
européenne et le temps si un seul un
soldat de l'otan qui traversent la
frontière c'est la troisième guerre
mondiale les gars préparer un préparez
vous avez vraiment ah oui fait sans
jamais vous êtes inquiet je suis très
inquiet ah oui en fait je cours je
comprends plus parce que jusqu'à
maintenant il a il avait un tout petit
peu de raisons jusqu'à la limite il
marchait sur le sur le fil de rasoir en
disant oui c'est pas nous c'est
l'ukrainien qui se battent entre eux
depuis huit ans et la mère de rossi qui
est a donc basculé à lougansk j'ai un
cousin russe qui est allé là bas on lui
a donné le passeport ukrainien on lui a
dit tu t'appelles maintenant par un mais
autrement telle prime vient donc en fait
c'était une guerre dont on parle de
troisième guerre mondiale c'est possible
parce que la puissance nucléaire c'est
tout à fait possible et j'ai une source
au kremlin qui m'a expliqué il ya trois
mois sur ma chaîne youtube ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui away mot pour mot il
ya plein de gens qui le disaient même
n'y a plus que trois mois il ya des gens
aujourd'hui un nom il ya quelques années
la plein de gens qui disaient que ça va
se passer et ce sera le début de la
troisième guerre mondiale vous savez ce
qu'il m'a dit ce matin
poutine il est capable aujourd'hui ou
demain ou après-demain faire exploser
une bombe à une kilotonnes juste pour
vous montrer ou jusqu'où il peut aller
c'est ça c'est pas un dégâts énormes
mais symboliquement voulzy vous imaginez
la dernière fois c'était il y aurait
jamais et nagasaki secteur lui il pense
il pense là ce matin et il était déjà à
tchernobyl tchernobyl c'est un réacteur
nucléaire avec les déchets nucléaires il
explose juste une petite bombe de rien
du tout toute la région c'est que la
région est laminée
il